Katniss
everine District
[Music]
oh
this
this thank you for your consideration
[Music]
for
what
[Music]
attention attention tributes there has
been a slight rule change the previous
revision allowing for two Victors from
the same district has been
revoked only one Victor may be crowned
good
luck and May the odds be ever in your
favor
go
ahead one of us should go
home one of us has to die they have to
have their
Victor
no they
don't why should
they no trust
me trust
me
[Music]
together
okay
one
two
[Music]
three
stop
stop ladies and
gentlemen may I present the winners of
the 74th Annual Hunger
Games what about you girl
fire any secrets worth my
time I'm an open book everybody always
seems to know my secrets before I know
them myself unfortunately I think that's
true I'm sorry you had to cancel your
wedding I know how devastating that must
be for
you have a good
day Peter finck
what' he want to know all my
secrets I have to get in
line out no waving and smiling this time
I want you to look straight ahead as if
the audience in this whole event are
beneath
you that should be
easy press this when you're ready good
luck
[Applause]
here they come from District 12 our
favorites well or my
[Applause]
[Music]
favorites
[Applause]
[Music]
there it is
oh fire in the
[Applause]
house
these tributes are crazy no not all of
them he's a good
guy carry
on you guys look amazing thank you my
stylist is such an idiot district 7
Lumber trees oh I'd love to put my axe
in her
face so what do you think now that the
whole world wants to sleep with you I
don't think that the whole world I
wasn't talking to you okay on
sit
yeah
thanks let's do it again sometime thank
you Jo animason district 7 I think we're
all here a little disappointed more than
a little disappointed that a certain
wedding did not take
place aren't we
folks alas but am I correct in ass uming
that this is the Gown that you would
have worn on that day yes or
no yes President Snow thought everyone
would want to see it well President Snow
as usual was
right was he not folks I love it I love
it don't you love it it's incredible and
so gorgeous will you do us the honor
please please
[Applause]
please
oh my
god
[Applause]
oh it's a bird if I got it's feathers
it's and it's like a it's like a bird
it's like a um um like a mocking J you
stylist certainly has outdone himself
this time hasn't he what theatricality
s Take a
[Applause]
Bow but
Peter the wedding the marriage never to
be well actually we got married in
secret a secret wedding all right d
tell we we want our love to be Eternal
cool you know kice and I we've been been
luckier than most I wouldn't have any
regrets at
all if if it
weren't it went for what what
what if it weren't for the
baby all right this is news let's find
out
more calm down this is news to all of us
the game all
[Applause]
right let's um everybody calm down it's
a great night great
night this is news to all of
us all right all right all right we're
going to find out what we do about this
[Applause]
[Music]
what
help
them help them get them
out
Katniss Katniss can you tell everyone
what you're seeing right
now katus what do you want to
say
I want the rebels to know that I'm
alive that I'm in District 8 where the
capital just bobbed a
hospital filled with unarmed men women
and children and there will be no
survivors if you think for one second
that the capital will ever treat us
fairly you are lying to
yourselves because we know who they are
and what they do this is what they do
and we must fight
back I have a message for President
Snow you can torture us and bomb us and
burn our districts to the
ground but do you see
that fire is
catching and if we burn you burn with
us
[Music]
hey
yeah that's a Maring
[Music]
J well now they'll never shut
up
you want me to
sing are you are
you coming to the tree they strung up a
man they say who murdered three strange
things that happen here stranger would
it be if we met at Mid night in the
Hanging Tree are you are you com the
tree where de man down for love to flee
strange things happen here no stranger
would it be if we met at Mid night in
the Hanging Tree are you are
you Thee I you run so we both be free
strange things did happen here no
stranger would it be if we met at Mid
night in the Hanging Tree are you are
you
theace
of line was originally necklace of rope
I had to change the necklace of Hope oh
you are true wordsi a little on the nose
but of course so is
war
p
p p get off get off over take
no
no no no no you're swirling don't touch
no no no calm down calm down you're
okay tell her she's
awake don't try to talk Peter's okay I
promise I just had to get him off
you
it's called
hijacking we don't know how long the
capital's been doing this to
Peter it's fear conditioning enhanced
with tracker Jacker Venom you were stung
your first games
remember the Venom puts the subject in a
dissociative
State they torture him with shocks and
beatings and strip down his identity and
then all of that suffering and fear is
redirected associated with other
memories or
person they can change his memories of
catniss to make her seem
life-threatening they turned him into a
weapon
Katniss to kill
you but you can reverse it fear is the
most difficult thing to overcome we're a
hardwired to remember fear best it's new
terrain but we've put together a
team I'm optimistic
[Music]
go go
go
got
[Music]
[Applause]
the
look
[Applause]
[Music]
look the go keep moving keep
moving
go go keep going keep
going
here come
on
[Music]
Peter Peter we have to keep going I'm we
have to keep going yes you can leave me
I'm a f look at me look at
me stay with
me
always come on
I know where we are I know a place up
those
[Music]
stairs keep
going
welcome to the new
panm
today on the Avenue of the
tributes all of PanAm a free PanAm will
watch more than a mere
spectacle we are gathered to witness an
historic moment of
Justice
today the greatest friend to the
revolution will find fire the shot to
end all
wars May her Arrow signify the end of
tyranny and the
beginning of a new
era Maring
J may your aim be as
true as your
heart
is
pure
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
get
[Music]
[Applause]
kill
did you have a
nightmare I have nightmares
too
someday I'll explain it to
you why they
came why they won't ever go
away but I'll tell you how I survive
it I make a list in my head of all the
good things I've seen someone
do every little thing I can
remember it's like a
game I do it over and
over gets a little tedious after all
these years
but there are much worse games to
[Music]
play